Alma's death critic I remember it so you
don't have to so I haven't done a top 11
list in a while and so I thought I would
do
you
my top 11 favourite South Park shop just
can tell you right now straightforward
there's a very strong chance that I will
not have your favorite South Park
episode on this list
ain't no one who can blame me it's
fuckin South Park and that's really
quite an accomplishment with most shows
people love fans can usually pick their
top 15 or even 20
but with South Park it's like top 30
your top 50 that's how many good
episodes there are and with them making
their way up to their 17th season they
show no sign of getting less clever
let's Rajee and most importantly less
funny they always know what subject to
tackle how to tackle it and how to get
the biggest laugh but inevitably we have
to ask which ones are the best with one
stand out with the best jokes best
parodies or even best messages they're
tough to sort out but I think I figured
my top 11 favorite why top 11 because I
like to go one step beyond so sit back
and enjoy the top 11 best South Park
episode yeah basically make that make
you the biggest bitch in the whole wide
world is a few big bitches there was a
big benefit to all the boys and girls
watching the biggest bitches over
number one Christian hardrock with
internet growing in popularity there was
still so many questions about what was
epic 'el and what wasn't what was
harmful stealing and what was innocent
fun and this episode exposed a lot of
the overhyped bullshit for what it was
the boys start their own band Moops then
decide to get online music for
inspiration little did they know though
that they were tapping into the woods
crime humanity could possibly perform at
least that's what the poor starving
musicians who already made millions of
dollars say here you see the loving
family of Master P next week is his
son's birthday and all he's ever wanted
is an island in French Polynesia so he's
gonna get it right I see an island
without an owner
we're sorry well we'll never download
music for free again the boys are so
blown away of what a terrible crime this
is that they decide to stop playing in
protest to protect their music and
become symbols for other big-name
artists who decide not to play never
realizing that Cartman who has started
his own fake Christian rock band which
it turns out is very easy all you do is
replace the word girl and they love song
with God it's making tons of money
because there's nobody else to listen to
forcing him to become a success
well they had a boy sit and do nothing
leaving them to sum up the position of
any artist perfectly but why play if
we're not gonna make millions of dollars
because that's what real art is do
people are always gonna find a way to
copy our music swap it for free if we're
real musicians then we should just play
and be stoked that so many people are
listening besides maybe our songs we've
gotten downloaded for free but if they
were good songs then people still what
about tickets to see our band in concert
we're not striking anymore who's with us
we're just about the money yeah yeah oh
this episode not only has great
commentary but it's another example of
keeping your eye off the prize and doing
what you love simply because you love
doing it
and with poorly written bill after
poorly written bill trying to get passed
in Congress to show the evils of the
Internet I think this is an argument
that won't be going away anytime soon
it's another great reminder to artists
that if you're doing it for the money
doing it for the wrong reason mad
learn to think of these horrible
outcomes before he acts selfishly or
else recording artists will be forever
doomed to a life of only semi luxury
number time Britney's new look
the boys are shocked at how much
attention Britney Spears is getting in
the media interrupting political debates
important news stories and sucking every
common person's attention and the news
about her is not really that interesting
either she just does something stupid
that in no way affects the world but the
world for some reason thinks that it
does and they hunt her down trying to
explain what a pathetic blood-sucking
creature she is never realizing that
they themselves are turning to the
pathetic blood sucking creatures even
after she pushes herself to the limit
shooting herself people still want to be
in on the shit that nobody should care
about it talks about the obsession with
celebrities our society has but South
Park asked the important question who
the fuck cares there's no doubt that
people love bullshit but this episode
says for the love of God get a fucking
life and stop thinking how you can live
through others it's like that show TMZ
you know the worst humanity has ever put
on in the history of the human race so
terrible that I hate getting a clip to
show you because I feel like getting the
footage is giving them a fraction of
support and that makes me feel like the
devil bad fucking bad and yet people
still watch them like they're saying
something important when all they're
doing is praying somebody will blow
their brains out to preserve whatever
measly shreds of journalistic decency
they have left
Jesus this episode exploits their
showing when no you know what I'm then
going a little longer
fuck me show if you're actually dumb
enough to watch past the first two
seconds without realizing
sucking whatever intelligence you had
but you deserve your purgatory of
rubbing templates on your genitalia
thinking you're getting played and
claiming to others that you know how the
world works what really is just trying
your virgin ass to sleep every night
while eating your Doritos and Captain
Crunch sandwiches no seriously you
stabbed God every time you see this show
you rape a kitten every time you go turn
the channel
fuck this shot not a fan this episode
displays a lot of similar issues that
were also brought up in raising the bar
and well that was a great episode I
thought this one did the obsession with
horse shit not only first but better for
whatever reason there will always be a
crowd for this stupid stuff and as long
as there is this episode will always
hold relevance unlike some other pieces
of shit seriously whoever's watching it
sleep with something for your own good
no we're not cancelled satire often
shows the flaws of human nature but once
in a while it can get it's humor from
the idea that maybe we've been doing
better than we thought
like we've actually been holding up when
given the circumstances we're put in and
this episode plays around with that idea
sort of it starts off eerily similar to
the very first episode in fact it's
exact that was the dream Cartman those
were visitors now is just a dream I'm on
set so visitors are real they wait a
minute this is all happened before yeah
this does seem really familiar but then
they realize they're reliving the same
events as before and discovered that the
aliens who implanted the satellite in
him from the first episode have returned
this of course raises the question why
was the satellite there to begin with
well it turns out earth is part of an
intergalactic reality show the idea
revolving around what happens when
various people and animals all live on
one planet our planet is just a reality
TV show what you don't think the whole
universe works the way earth does do you
know one species one planet there's a
planet of dear planet evasions and so on
we put them all together on earth and
the whole universe Tunes in to watch the
fun this immediately creates conflict
violence drama which of course equals
entertainment but the problem is people
are suddenly made aware of it sixes
so because of the fear of it not being
as fun anymore the show is in danger of
being cancelled resulting in Earth's
destruction so the boys have to convince
the aliens that mankind is still violent
still crazy and still has the need to
keep world peace as far away from them
as possible
so they can be renewed for another
season and the earth doesn't have to be
destroyed they had to promote the worst
of humanity in order to save the best of
humanity not only is it a great callback
to the first episode but it's also both
the most optimistic and pessimistic
combination you can imagine turning the
mere act of existing into a form of
business and entertainment this episode
shows clearly not only what's good TV
but what keeps it good TV
I'm sure you'll see that if you give our
world time it will become even more
outrageous and violent number Jim
Pokemon let's face it whether you love
Pokemon or just didn't fucking
understand it there was no ignoring the
impact that it was having kids
everywhere became obsessed making the
anime style bigger than it had ever been
in the past so this is TRAI Matt's very
adult outsider look on the phenomenon
and as someone who's going into college
by the time this shit became popular and
didn't follow it at all I can guarantee
it got most people's reaction to it come
on hurry don't see Trump Pinkett shoot
lamb toy collector Marlon you can become
royal crown chinpokomaster Tim Pokemon
is super
so they're trying to understand the show
and why it's so damn weird the parents
discover a plot from the Japanese to
brainwash all of America's kids forming
an army to conquer the world
this not only mocked the intense fandom
of children at the time but also how
diabolical marketing can be and that
with the right combination of crazy-ass
ideas can form an empire of epic
proportions
even to world domination apparently just
look at this subtle propaganda you can't
the wait they're gone it was just a
great what the fuck reaction to all the
adults trying to understand what their
kids are watching and that as much as we
like to push good intelligent
programming on them kids are always
gonna like something stupid too
it's just the way of life someday I will
collect all the Chinpokomon then I will
find evil power that will reveal itself
once all the Chinpokomon a collector oh
no Katie you can't have you chicken
tenders they cut down man and I came out
to my cab oh it was great seeing the
oddness of children's anime shows they
mock so well but this would of course
raise the question what about adult
anime well join me in numbers
number seven good times with weapons
first much as they mocked kids enemy
it's fairly obvious the writers of the
show must enjoy good adult anime as well
in this episode the boys come across a
series of weapons and pretend that
they're ninjas
but not just any ninjas anime injustice
and the best thing is we don't see it
from an outsider point of view like we
do with geppu c'mon we see it from the
children's point of view everything
found in traditional anime is here the
badass designs the over-the-top
storylines even the karaoke songs with
bad English dubbing let's go to taisetsu
na mono
Wow a lot of the humor comes from the
fact that it's taking a simple story
about kids playing and turning it into a
grand battle so the company lies in how
over the top and epic they're making
their childish dilemmas and nobody does
it over-the-top and epic like anime it's
a living send up with lots of labs and a
perfect satire of a very popular article
we'd love to hang out guys but we have
important secret work to do yes the lack
of an inch is complexing foot a pair it
even has a funny wheel jab at the end
about violence in the media versus sexy
feet and it wraps up all this ends
really nicely but hell we all know that
wasn't the best part the best part was
just watching them make fun of what we
enjoy but still in a loving way what
else can you say but number six make
love not war craft at the height of the
online role-playing game craze South
Park took a look at one of the most
popular if not the most popular RPG ever
Warcraft the boys don't discover
Warcraft and become instantly hooked the
only downside is there's one player out
there who has spent God knows how many
hours building up his experience points
making him the most powerful character
in the game allowing him to kill him
bully whatever he wants this pisses off
the boys to know it so they decide they
want to get revenge but the only way to
do it is to build up their experience
points so the boys decide to sacrifice
all their social life to become the
mightiest fighters online and the most
pathetic human waste in reality much
like good times with weapons a lot of
the humor comes from how a large our
heroes can make something so not
epically large I mean they can be
fighting online but when you get down to
it they're just sitting at a fucking
computer screen and we always get
constant reminder seeing all our badass
looking characters still have the voices
of little kids
I just took the biggest crap dude we've
been waiting forever well I'm sorry I
had to take it down another great thing
about this episode is that so much of it
is done in CG and actually acquired the
help of Blizzard Entertainment the
company that created Warcraft again like
good times with weapons though the
episode mocks the material as well as
its fans but also shows the appreciation
for it too
it acknowledges why the game is so
popular and how it can become so
addictive it just shows what happens
when the addiction can go too far
whoever this person is he is played
World of Warcraft nearly every hour of
every day for the past year and a half
we are dealing with someone here who has
absolutely no life how do you kill that
which has no life but it still shows it
is fun and even though people can take
it to ridiculous extremes there's still
something very enjoyable about it yeah
how did you get that no time just take
it here how how do you hand something
from one player to another bring up your
inventory screen control I okay so again
we have sort of a loving tribute
obviously taking a few punches here and
there I don't have a World of Warcraft
account to you know I have a life but
still enjoying the fact that something
so mundane can be turned into such a
huge adventure it has a perfect
understanding of the fans the material
and even the idea behind the material
hey if even Blizzard can acknowledge how
funny it is it must be doing something
right yep I want to get that up at the
bad guy
passion of the Jew definitely a classic
the best look at Mel Gibson's
controversial film The Passion of the
Christ so people may forget but this
film was one of the most talked about
movies for a couple years and South Park
decided to throw in their two cents as
well all the boys go to see the film
based on how everybody's been talking
about it and each one has a different
reaction Kyle sees as a guilt trip
because of his Jewish heritage
Cartman sees as a chance to control
brainwashed extremist and Stan and Kenny
just see it as now that bad film that
wasn't a movie that was a snuff film
which I give a lot of credit for seeing
how this is the following joke this is
about being able to hold bad filmmakers
responsible just like when we got our
money back for bass ketball they try to
go to Mel Gibson himself to try and get
their money back but their fears of
Gibson being a crazy pain obsessed
sadomasochists are sadly confirmed in
fact overly confirmed I guess now you
got to start torturing me Wow my nipples
are so tender don't squeeze them anymore
dude what's wrong with him
he's cuckoo dude it addressed every
issue that people talked about with the
film anti-semitism Jewish guilt the
overuse of violence religious extremes
focus of faith then just how bad shit
insane Mel Gibson is even before I was
commonly known today it seems like this
episode was trying to do what most of
their episodes tried to do mock
over-the-top extreme is by using
ironically over-the-top extremes but
their extreme served as a mere to all
the other complainers saying hey if
you're gonna preach something make sure
it's something that's good or as they
say it you want to be Christian that's
cool but you should follow what Jesus
taught instead of how he got killed
focusing on how he got killed is what
people did in the dark ages and it ends
up with really bad results that about
sums it up because when you get down to
it they don't attack how people
represent religion at faith they attack
how people declare a movie represents
religion and faith and how that's just
as much bullshit as it sounds and this
episode called it out whatever your
thoughts whatever your beliefs make sure
you're following good ethics for good
reasons you know what I'd love to
torture me wouldn't you
he's not quite as eloquent desired
picture only four more to go we'll get
to him right after these ads so keep an
eye out for this one he's Saturday and
on Sunday you can't the way to go I
don't trust it
you
is it well to count three episodes is
one fuckin I'm doing it anyway let's
move on to the Kuhn trilogy yeah even
though the Coon made a few appearances
before you all know which episodes I'm
talking about the Cthulhu episodes
that's right this is a three parter with
episodes kun to hindsight mysterion
Rises and kun versus Coonan friends they
split into threes and for good reason so
much happens that it needs to be split
into three but they still flow perfectly
as one the trilogy starts with Cartman
as a superhero character called the coop
being thrown out as superhero group
Coonan friends because well he's Cartman
and he's a fan yes but as luck would
have it a BP drill goes AWOL again and
accidentally unleashes cut Foom but
don't worry they apologize for it we're
sorry we're sorry
sorry Carmen takes his chance to
befriend Cthulhu and take his revenge
out on his friends while that's
happening there's epic drama going on
with one of the team members mysterion
trying to discover his origin there's
also great appearances from characters
like Captain hindsight professor chaos
and of course
mintberry crunch where do I begin with
this episode not only does it satirise
everything from comic books to anime to
current events to fucking Chuck Jones
cartoons but it surprisingly also stands
on its own as a very good story at least
from a comedic standpoint this could
twist mysteries and reveals all
throughout three episodes even down to
which kid is playing with super hero
even that gets a huge laugh and
sometimes as with mysterion it ties into
the story
the exposition at the end about one of
the characters background is so funny
and so unexpected it's impossible not to
laugh your ass off the way it can act so
large when such silly ridiculous stuff
is going on is an epic comedy marvel it
blends styles and mixes genres to create
its own little epic I know many people
would probably prefer the
Imaginationland saga and yeah that was
pretty funny too
but this ones need to have a more
defined look with harsher shadows and
backgrounds and also in my opinion just
funnier jokes and more character out of
all the really big action-packed
episodes they've ever done this will not
only seem the biggest but the best put
together yeah action it had trauma it
had questions it had answers it left
everybody satisfied the one very
important question remains why the hell
isn't there a mid berry crime serial
seriously it advertises itself can we
get a Kickstarter for this
number three woodland critters Christmas
actually talked about this on my top 11
Christmas specials of all time list so I
won't talk in too much detail about it
partly because so much of the humor does
rely on how many twists and turns it
throws at you the special centers around
Stan who one Christmas comes across a
series of talking animals called the
woodland critters they're excited
because porcupinie the porcupine isn't
that great name
it's giving birth to the Lord and Savior
and honestly I should just stop right
there if I was to talk any more about
the story it would give away great
reveal after great reveal and he was to
say every single one of them gets a huge
laugh it's not just a great satire of
Christmas specials God even that music
seems to sum up every Christmas song
ever made it's once a year it's
Christmastime
it's once a year Christmas ha
when we hear about how Christmas only
comes once a year but as stories go this
one is probably the best written there
are so many surprises around every
corner and each of them gets funnier
than the last and every single time you
think they're done with comedic payoffs
they always have at least five other
ready for you and they all tie in to
make an absolutely perfect episode I
know I'm being really vague about it but
trust me if you've seen this episode
you'll know what I'm talking about when
you hear South Park does a Christmas
special this is just the kind of stuff
that would pop in your head
shocking dark and bad taste but also so
unbelievably funny again I'm sorry I
can't go into more detail like it did
the other ones especially seeing how
it's so high up on the list but I really
do believe that the reveal of the humor
is that good and I simply don't want to
ruin it for you it's one of my favorite
Christmas specials for that very reason
and I think it's Ella South Park's
greatest Friday
number two all about Mormons I think
it's safe to say the careers of South
Park have a fascination with Morris but
given the way they explain it and make
jokes about it you can kind of see why
in this episode a family of Mormons move
into the neighborhood at first they're
outcasts because everyone thinks they're
gonna try and force their beliefs down
their throats as the town's preparing
for our fight the morons are preparing
for dinner
yeah not only do they not want to fight
back but they constantly invite people
over for dinner and it's not for any
religious agenda or anything they're
just nice what happened I'm going over
to his house for dinner tonight
you kick mr. Harrison's ass we're at
having their family over for dinner
tomorrow night
see that's what happened to me they talk
politely they tell stories they're a
better family than most of the families
in town and the episode is pretty much
the villages confusion of how such kind
people can come from a religion that's
well according to South Park something
like this Jesus lived here in America
yes eventually my people were all killed
by the other tribe of Israel and as
punishment God turned their skin red
these are the Native Americans you know
today
this episode is one of the best for two
reasons one if you've ever known a
Mormon you know they are unusually nice
and ethical and not angry and just what
was it oh I'm sure there's some asshole
Mormons out there but I haven't met him
yet
I haven't even met a person who met a
Mormon who was an asshole yet so the
grasp of Mormon people is not only funny
but kind of dead-on but the second thing
that makes this episode one of the best
is that it still takes its shots at the
Mormon religion but that still doesn't
get in the way of their message being
that if a religion doesn't spread hate
produces good people and hurts no one
told cares what the hell they think in
my opinion I'll even think this needs to
be called all about Mormons it can be
called all about religion no matter what
the faith if it seems to spread good
without harming a soul there's good in
it as much as the episode does Mock the
Mormon religion it also surprisingly
teaches tolerance in its own unique self
parky way heck Stan's father was to
become a Mormon because he just wants to
figure out how he can be as nice and
complete as their family is and it all
comes from just being Pleasant and you
know what in a show that can be so harsh
and being spirited sometimes it's good
to know that even the creators can still
see the value and just straight up being
nice even in the face of being mocked
for it and in the end the Mormon kid is
actually seen as the badass because he
didn't change for anything he just
stayed himself because that's what he
liked in a time where religion can still
be so complicated and so controversial
this episode understands that sometimes
the simplest answer can very well be the
best who's up for water balloon fights
yeah
and now for my number one pick keep an
open mind number one best South Park
episode is Osama bin Laden has farty
pants poet let me explain the reason why
I think this is the best episode it's
not the funniest episode it's not the
smartest episode it's not even the best
ridden episode but it came at a time
when America needed South Park it had
been three months since the previous
South Park episode and in that time not
only did 9/11 happen but a series of
anthrax attacks that was being sent
through the mail was putting the country
in a state of absolute fear security
tightened everywhere our country was on
the brink of war America was changed
forever nobody knew how or what to feel
so when the news that South Park was
going to return to TV was announced a
lot of people were wondering what are
they gonna do what could they do would
it be a touching episode and in depth
episode what side would they pick what
issues were they going to tackle what
the hell was South Park going to do
literally the first frame set the mood
another one like is to be simple and
cool not really this is what we needed
we needed a good laugh at the entire
thing and we needed it to be done by
South Park the episode shows the overly
secured and paranoid America waving
flags everywhere for support and hiding
in their homes feeding their fear by
watching the news through a
misunderstanding the boys are forced to
send a dollar each to Afghanistan kids
as part of a charity program and they
have returned send a goat they don't
want the goat oh I wish to return it via
plane but end up getting caught in the
flight through per usual a strange
series of events the boys end up
discovering Osama bin Laden and the rest
of the show is just making him look like
the most pathetic ass Oh Ben fella
feliformia more a fatwa fatwa it was as
over-the-top
raunchy silly and cartoony as they had
ever been in the past oh I got him I got
him everybody was talking about it the
next day did you see that episode of
South Park wasn't it hilarious that was
just what I needed
God and glad they're still so funny
therap and jokes made about the state of
our country before this episode other
sand tires and commentaries but this was
the one that Americans needed
uncompromising unapologetic not worrying
about who they offended just trying to
make people laugh it was just the right
jokes at just the right time delivered
by just the right people
Giuliani showed us we needed to be
strong Letterman showed us we needed to
cry
South Park showed us we needed to laugh
I'm not gonna say it changed everything
or erased all our fears that we had
before but a good comedian knows the
power of laughing and how important it
is it not only makes you feel good but
it can help you out through some of the
darkest moments of your life and in one
of America's darkest moments this helped
a great deal
it helped us in only the strange ways
South Park can help us by not backing
down to anything and just doing what
they thought was fun
and whether it was a huge war or the
tiniest little chuckle everybody felt
their spirits raise a little bit after
seeing this episode it's the best
episode because it's the only episode
that reminds us that we not only like
South Park but we surprisingly needed
so there you go my top 11 favorite South
Park episodes I'm looking back it's kind
of shocking how smart it is from a show
that most people thought was just
lowbrow garbage and crude childish humor
South Park is proven to be some great
social satire and purely on its own
terms they're the people we can always
rely on to say the emperor has no
clothes the people who won't be bought
out or cave into any public opinion the
people who won't hold back about saying
something about somebody because they
were afraid they might be on the show or
they might be a sponsor they have no
fear because they have no cares they
talk about whatever they think is funny
and still managed to be relevant for 17
seasons and still going strong maybe
there is more the South Park than just
crude humor maybe it's proof that great
comedy and art doesn't just come from
freedom but from freedom given to the
right people and that what the public
claims is one day being beneath them or
immature nonsense can the next day be
claimed as some of the most blunt
straightforward and brilliant satire
that television has seen in years when
Joe Greene
take your fucking dick hoes you done
keep flipping shitty guys go outside and
get a Sun I get
and the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you didn't have to
do those tourniquets
you
you ever wonder what would happen if the
cinema snob turned to one of those
pretentious filmmakers he makes fun of
the darkest recesses of my nightmares
won't allow me to think about it but
luckily this film exists to show me what
the outcome would be
it has sex murder mayhem and probably
the biggest collection of bearded men
since the last temptation of Christ but
is it on par with main writer and actor
Brad Jones's other work well he does
keep his cat out of most of the shots
let's get our freak on with paranoia
you
last bite